it
is february 1st 2021 so it's time for
another
monthly update video and there's a lot
going on
in february that you're probably going
to want to know about but there there
was a lot that went
on in january as well that you might
have missed
and so you can check it out if you click
show more or whatever the equivalent is
in your your youtube interface you'll
see that
the video description and that will have
links to all of the
sorts of things that i'm talking about
in this particular video
so you can find out you know the
calendar all the other
uh places where you can you can find out
about these events and
view videos listen to podcasts and
you know whatever else you're looking
for so i always like to begin with
three big things that are going to be
coming up this month
big thing number one is that we have
crossed a major milestone in the
half-hour hegel project that's
oriented around hegel's phenomenology of
spirit
we are now moving into the religion
section of the work
uh finishing the spirit section so we're
getting close to the end
of the project and i'm going to be
having a special event this month to
commemorate that
big thing number two we're having
another event which
is a local milwaukee event but it's
going to be broadcast worldwide so
anybody who wants to join in on it can
and the
theme is you know because it's february
valentine's day love is in the air
we're going to be talking about
understanding personal and romantic
relationships by
using aristotle's theory of friendship
which can be very
helpful for for many people so i'll be
doing a workshop that you can
participate in
and big thing number three something
that we didn't actually get to last
month but got close to being able to
release and we will be doing this month
in the study with sadler online academy
people you know always ask do you have
online classes
i do indeed that you can take and i'll
be
uh bringing out at least one new class
perhaps
multiple classes this month so that's
what's going on those are some of the
big things
coming up obviously there's a lot more
now let's talk about
january so what went on
in the month of january well we had a
lot of
online events as always these are
regularly scheduled things that we do
each month
we had our half hour hegel q a and
discussion sessions
one for the public one for supporters of
the project
i held an ama that's ask me anything
session online the video for that
available below also available below
will be the political theory and
practice discussion
which centered on you know in part where
do we go from here
do we have to think about uh having
unity or should we
attempt to have unity in this fractured
polity that we we inhabit there's also
uh
you know we did the worlds of
speculative fiction
series uh first session of the year i
think it was uh
number 48 because we're going into our
sixth year on
chinese writer thinker
sci-fi author and i would argue
philosopher
lutzi shin and his remembrance of
earth's past
trilogy which was quite a lot of fun
big thing of course classes started for
the year i'm teaching
classes for milwaukee institute of art
and design carthage college and
milwaukee area technical college
the matc is the second chance pell
program
for wisconsin inmates who write class
with me
remotely and you know class is starting
there's always a lot of
planning and work to do ahead of time
there's usually
some things that get you know screwed up
there's some snags
more with some schools than with others
i'm not going to name names
but i will tell you that that some
schools are particularly well organized
and others are
very disorganized
but you know everything is off to to a
good start now
i did a few interviews one is on a
podcast called the
todd say own podcast i'll put a link to
that below
and something that just released quite
recently the world class performer
interview by by text it's a written
interview that they did with me
so you may want to check that out as
well i did a lot of video work this this
last month
um event videos of course are links are
below
i did some caption contest videos people
seem to really enjoy
chiming in on those and and watching
them um
i did a video specifically about the
sadler's lectures
podcast because i've had people now
asking me
for quite some time hey man when are you
going to start a podcast and the answer
is
oh you know around 2018 when i did start
a podcast so
you can check that out if you don't know
about the sadler's lectures podcast
i've got over 300 episodes now at this
point
wisdom for life the radio show that i do
with my co-host dan hayes for riverwest
radio which streams worldwide we also
record
our sessions so there's a video about
our latest session that you can watch
i did five half hour hegel videos this
month which is definitely an
improvement over previous months i'm not
quite at the quota of six but i got
pretty close this time
i'm really happy about that and i did
some core concept videos
as well one of my classes this semester
is on philosophy as a way of life
and so i did videos on foucault's
technologies of the self
john seller's excellent article what is
philosophy as a way of life and pure
adoles
spiritual exercises all of those have
been released except for some of the
adult ones
and i managed to get a book review video
done i'm really proud of that and it is
on a really great book
piera does selected essays which has
been recently
translated and released so
that's uh all stuff that you can watch
as far as the podcast goes
i did i think at the very beginning of
the month i was still
working on releasing aristotle uh nick
mccain ethics
podcast episodes then we shifted into
cicero's on
friendship which eventually down the
line i'm going to put together a class
on
for people and then towards the end of
the month we
started doing some on plato's
dialogue the meno for some of my
students this
this semester where we're reading that
text in class
i had a lot of new tutorial
and philosophical counseling clients
which is always cool
uh particularly since i i barely do any
marketing so people are finding their
way to me
and i really enjoy that that sort of
work working with clients one on one
if you're interested in that sort of
thing of course you know go to my
website reasonio.com and you'll
find out about those services there
that's probably enough for
january what do we have coming
up in the month of february very short
month which is going to be
quite packed fortunately it seems to and
i didn't plan it this way be a bit
front loaded we're doing more stuff in
the beginning of the month than we are
during the
later part of the month so i might
actually have some time to
you know reorient myself before getting
into march
so here's the calendar of events all of
these are
in central time so you do want to make
sure you check on your
time zone on the second that's tomorrow
at 6 p.m we have our
mke that's milwaukee sophia that's
society of philosophers in america
chapter media we
are going to be talking about um same
sort of topic
aristotle three kinds of friendship
personal relationships because this is
february
it's the month of love right love is in
the air because of valentine's day or at
least
anxiety about all these sorts of matters
is
and perhaps uh desperation and despair
but
we'll be talking about more positive
things in the meeting
and anybody's will you know welcome to
join us you don't have to be in
milwaukee because these things are
online
anybody can come in from from anywhere
they like
uh on the sixth that's a saturday at 12
p.m we'll have our ama that's ask me
anything
session with youtube live you ask a
question
i hopefully get around to answering it
we get more questions and we can
actually devote
time to so you do want to get your
question in early
and i do try to make sure that i i don't
answer you know like
30 questions by one person and ignore
somebody else so
you know it's kind of it is first come
first served but we also do want to try
to have a wide range
of people so don't deluge it with a
bunch of questions figure out what one
question you want to ask
on the 6th at 2 p.m following
the ama i have a much more intimate
session for my patreon supporters
called philosophy chat if you're
interested in that consider becoming a
supporter
you get to have some more one-on-one or
sometimes you know three on one or five
on one depending on how many people show
up for it
time asking me about whatever it is that
you want to discuss
within my realms of competency
on the seventh the day after that at uh
12 that's noon central we will be having
a hegel party
like the hail parties that we've had in
the past when we crossed an important
threshold we have now moved into the
religion section
patreon supporters of the half-hour
hegel project which is a different
patreon by the way than the general
patron
have already seen the first three videos
of the religion section i'll be
releasing
one of them later on this week and we're
gonna have a little
you know get together online using
youtube live
i'll do a little bit of talking about
the project and
religion and hegel and answering
people's comments and questions
and maybe we'll we'll even do like a
little toast or something to celebrate
moving into the
the news section and getting close to
the end of this project that's been
going on for
six or seven years um on the 10th
a wednesday at 5 00 p.m i'll be having
my
public hegel q a and discussion session
that's a video conferencing
session done with zoom anybody can come
in and ask questions about hegel
get some clarifications i might be able
to help you i might not we'll see you
know but i'll certainly
take a stab at it if you if you
uh come in with some good questions on
the 13th
at 10 p.m we're going to be having that
event that i was talking about in the
three big things
so this is a local milwaukee event
and we are actually going to be uh you
know partnering with some other
organizations and taking donations for
um you know some some shelters
and it's focused specifically on how to
use
aristotle's insights about friendship
and relationships
to understand one's own relationships
and perhaps improve them
change them cut some of them off you
know seek out new relationships
so that is going to be a very practical
philosophy
oriented thing anybody can can tune in
from anywhere around the world
if they want to links are of course
below
also on the 13th at 12 noon and
at 1 30 because we have two parts to
this event we'll have
worlds of speculative fiction and this
time we're looking at
philip k dick who we've looked at before
in the past but this time we're looking
at novels that have to do
with colonization of space
and with insanity two important themes
in his work i'm going to be joined by a
special guest
michael gomez a good friend and
colleague who
is a practicing psychotherapist and a
trainer for psychotherapists
and we are going to be he's going to i'm
going to be tapping his brain
you know these these designations of or
or diagnoses have changed over
time so i'm going to be asking so dick
was you know talking about people being
schizoid or you know psychotic what how
do we talk about that today
what what's actually going on with that
so we're going to tap his
expertise he's also a big sci-fi fan and
i think he's as big of a [ __ ] as i
am
you know that's the name for fans of
philip k dick so
that should be a lot of fun uh i think
people will want to join in on that
so 12 o'clock is when the video that's
just
me talking about the these novels and
the key themes and world building and
stuff like that
that's a video premiere with live chat
with me and then 1 30
it's a zoom video conferencing with me
and michael
talking about all of this stuff
so that that'll be a lot of fun i think
um
on the 20th at 12 noon
another collaborator of mine a guitar
professor
and studio and touring musician scott
tarrouli
he's going to be joining me once again
for our classic
metal class this time i've decided that
the topic
we're going to be going over the the the
ocean
to talk about american metal in the 70s
and particularly
in the 80s and and what's going on so
it'll be a lot of musical history but
there will be some
philosophy stuff involved no doubt
um on the 21st at 12 we will also have
our political theory
and practice discussion topic for that
is at this point tba and we'll we'll get
to that
later on and then finally wrapping up
the month on the 25th
at 6 00 p.m we will have our mke stoic
fellowship monthly meeting that's
milwaukee stoic fellowship
people join from all over the world we
are going to be starting our
study and discussion of cicero's
important work on duties and
um so if you if you're interested in
that work
pop in and join us for that
there is one other thing coming up that
i do want to
mention and that is that my wife
and i are um
we are co-hosting and guest hosting for
the sunday stoic on valentine's day so
andy and i
for years have been doing talks and
workshops on
stoicism and relationships particularly
romantic relationships
she and i have both found it quite
useful and
have used you know stoicism to grow in
the process without losing the spark of
passion so we're going to be
doing an episode on the sunday stoic
about that
you can listen in on on that sunday
which is valentine's day
got a lot of video work to do
um the events videos of course i'm going
to try to get my
quota of six half hour hegel videos done
this month all in the new religion
section
i want to get some more book reviews
done i got one done last month i want to
shoot for four
this month i'll probably do at least one
more
caption video since people seem to be
into that sort of stuff
and i'm going to be releasing some
sadler's stories since people have been
asking for more of those personal
narratives
when it comes to core concept videos
these are largely things that i'm
producing for my students in my online
classes
so i've got a few more adult videos to
release
and then i'm going to be shooting this
is the order of things
and then i have to shift gears a little
bit to do some videos on
peter singer on boethius and
on hobbs i'm not sure how many of them
i'll release
this month we'll see you know but
i'm certainly going to grind away and
try to get as much of this done as i can
last thing the saddlers lectures podcast
i need to i'm going to be releasing a
few more plato ones
that i need to start doing some more new
content specifically on
seneca's letters on aquinas uh
somatiologia mostly stuff having to do
with happiness
and on david hume's inquiry concerning
human understanding so stay tuned for
all of those things coming out
hope you can join me for some of these
online events and i hope you have a
great month ahead
you